la francia industrial se veía abocada al
abismo y wild pool era un símbolo
apropiado hace cinco años una sede del
fabricante de electrodomésticos
estadounidenses situada en la ciudad
norteña de amianto estaba a punto de
cerrar y se convirtió en el escenario de
una competencia crucial entre los
candidatos a la segunda vuelta marín de
penn y emanuel macrón
la señora le pen está utilizando a la
gente con fines políticos está arengando
a los activistas en un aparcamiento
mientras macrón se reunía con los
líderes sindicales de la ciudad lepén
eclipsó dirigiéndose directamente a la
fábrica donde recibió una calurosa
bienvenida
no se cerrará utilizaremos todos
nuestros recursos para que no se cierren
para no ser menos macrón se dirigió al
lugar más adelante y pasó la tarde
siendo sometido a la presión de los
manifestantes fue el primer gran ataque
y enfrentamiento de la segunda vuelta de
2017 el segundo llegó con el debate
televisado un verdadero golpe para el
epen
volvemos al franco o no tenemos que
volver a nuestra moneda nacional
entonces volvemos al franco es vital
vital así que definitivamente está
sugiriendo que dejemos del euro voy a
renegociar para que nos liberemos del
euro y lo convirtamos en una moneda
común
lepén ha admitido desde entonces que
este debate fue un fracaso que ya fue
demasiado agresiva por contra se
considera la victoria decisiva en la
campaña de macrón de 2017
esta vez lepén reducirá al parecer sus
apariciones públicas durante tres días
antes del debate para prepararlo